ISL
[Silence]
the
in
[Silence]
alhamdulillah alhamd
ald
[Silence]
ald muhamad
subham
[Silence]
dear brothers and
sisters Mah today we have beautiful
days and blessed
days
because we are to with our
with us today IM
didar I love this
Iman and Allah subhah wa ta'ala make
him mallah he is
IM M Greenway in
Phoenix always I visit him and always
invite
me I ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
put us together with
you in the
J with the prophet Muhammad s Al
wasallam and shade the throne Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
I want to say thank you dmar for coming
to
MCC sh
will take from your
knowledge we all will be benefited from
you thank you so much
[Silence]
I feel extremely humbled after the
beautiful words of she waik he's our
Sheikh by the way I consider I would
consider myself not just saying it it's
not just a saying it but literally I
mean it I would consider myself to be
his student and it is kind of you
know shameful for me to you know to to
make a speech in front of him but this
is from his F that Allah subhana wa tala
has given to him and we believe that
each one of us can share one word here
and there and we all can benefit and at
the end the Islam is a reminder it's a
reminder it's just a
reminder
the Quran orders it's a command
remind even the Arabs they know that
there is one Allah subhana wa tala but
because they got too much into politics
and into money and into all of that so
they started worshiping Idols they
create the idols so they can have more
money they can have more business they
can have more travel as they can 360
Idol inside the Caba that's why they
needed to be reminded even though mam
when he went in front of the
Pharaoh Allah he said to
M you know maybe perhaps you know he
might come to to realize he might come
to remember about my existence or he may
come to fear
me so at the end whatever we say
sometimes we put new things in our in
our lectures in our speeches you know we
hear we read here there some books some
Scholars some but at the end it's all a
reminder because the reminders
definitely
it is
y it's benefit it's beneficial it
benefits the
Believers so I consider this to be again
just as a reminder nothing too much new
since the Sheikh was mentioning some
he started you know and the sh
actually they do that always you know
praising prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he praised The Prophet by
including him in the Dua and he you know
that was probably the the best speech he
said it already
the best spee was already said when he
said oh Allah resurrect us all together
we are with the prophet sallallahu
alai wasallam you
know and I had to talk about
something else but now my attention is
all towards the prophet Sall wasallam
you know and I I I cannot start saying
what I wanted to say without going
through that
first one of the things that a lot of
people they miss
when it comes to the
prophet is that they consider him to be
only as a delivery
man somebody who was supposed to come
deliver the Quran and just go off you
know some deliver pizza delivery brings
to you the pizza and you tip couple
dollars right there off you go see you
next week or next day if you order again
Pizza some people who unfortunately
really they consider the
prophet in that way and this is really
unfair now we make our case we say no
Prophet is not like
that Prophet is not just a delivery man
and we bring you facts from the
Quran and the facts are yes he was
indeed a man he was a man but he was
[Arabic recitation]
Alam I am a me I am a human just like
you however Revelation is being you know
coming down to me is being descended to
me so now does this make him just a
regular human yes he is indeed a human
but not any other
human the
of he was a
he accepted Islam when he
was in his middle age around his
middle
age and these Nation they sent him they
said oh Hassan they said go and
intimidate the prophet because you know
back in the days the Arabs they would
bring somebody up just by a couple of
lines of poetry right there you know and
everybody automatically starts
respecting you or if they wanted to
bring somebody down
they would just say couple words of
poetry right there couple lines of
poetry and you write it down no matter
how rich you are no matter how
protection you have and all of that they
had that influence in the
society so when went to you know
intimidate the prophet he
said when I went in front of him and I
looked at his an he doesn't say
you know they came forth all of these an
all of these NES they just came forth
like
that and you know they prescribe him the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasam they
prescrib him as the best man ever lived
IM Ali and Hassan or Hussein or so many
other Companions and relatives and
the I'm focusing on the companions they
say that we have never seen anybody like
him before and we have never seen
anybody him after after he passed
away now the question is why why do they
say this he he was a human you know when
they give the description they say he
was a human he had hair he had 14 gray
hairs he had 20 gray hair different
narration from Malik
in you know they say Prophet was middle
midsize you know they explain the hair
and the teeth and so we come to
understand that he was a human right he
looked a human beautiful human but
a human at the end but they say he
possessed this light so much light with
him the teachings I mean Scholars number
one they say that yes indeed he had a
light too
new but also Above This it was the
teachings he would deliver these
teachings from him into his companions
and those teachings were reflected back
to
him so this is this is all
no another another companion for example
he
says he says I was looking one night at
the moon and then one night at the
prophet I mean and again looking back at
the moon and then looking at the prophet
looking at the mo I came to understand I
came to realize it says the prophet
sallallahu alai wasam is more beautiful
than the moon itself and more radiant
more radiant and more beautiful than the
moon
itself you know he's comparing I mean
his teachings right here that his
teachings they enlighted the hearts of
the people that's why people accepted
Islam all over not only in in Arabia but
even in other other countries India and
Indonesia Malaysia Europe I'm from
Europe from
Albania Albania with
Arabia thousands of miles away they
didn't have back in the days internet to
start chatting and doing hey we got
Islam and all that
no there
were there
[Silence]
were they are manad firm man not just no
no their
man their man
they are afraid you know the the the the
business of this world materialism does
not scare them off they don't say we
cannot come for the prayer because we
got to be the
business I know business
owners they have employees and I know
they can make that for the prayer J
prayer they would say no no no that's
too much it's our priority it's our food
it's our life business I got to be at
the business
they don't consider materialism in other
words they do not consider materialism
above above the remembrance of Allah
subhah wa this
is it's
all so these are man these are real man
they they are scared from a day when
their hearts and their Vision will be
trembled they're not afraid because
they're going to lose their houses or
they're going to lose their
businesses or they're going to lose
their
lotteries or they're going to lose in
gambling
no they fear a d day when the hearts and
the Visions you know sighing is going to
be
trembled in the day of
judgment so again going back to what
we're talking
about Al wasall I'm saying that this is
what he expressed this is what he taught
to his companions this is what the nor
was or let's say this was a part of the
N that he gave to these Companions and
they took this new and they spread it
all over over the
world and because of this new people
accepted Islam they realize this n not
only with their eyes but with their
hearts so it enter their hearts
automatically and when the IM goes into
your heart it penetrate your hearts it's
it's hard it's hard to leave it it's
hard to say n it's hard to put business
on top of the
J it's hard to go to bed without
mentioning Allah subhah wa tala it just
doesn't make sense it's unre to you
anymore it's it's it's not you anymore
so you live with that because IM has
penetrated your
hearts and IM also in his
book of
when he talks about
the he says
that that the servant does not exit the
faith
except by
rejecting that which he believed which
made him a Believer you know you hear
sometimes people oh he drank alcohol
CF oh he committed a major CF
no as long as he did not reject that
which made him a Believer the faith
which is the faith because when Faith
penetrates the
heart you know that's it and we see this
transformation with without our own s we
are the best examples of that this
Gathering is an example of that we have
no interest except to meet with each
other to hear a couple words I benefit
from you you benefit from me we benefit
from the Sheikh you
know it's just
simply subhah
waala love for the sake of Allah subhana
[Arabic recitation]
tala when an angel was you know seeing a
person walking and going to meet another
brother he says where are you going he
says he says I'm going to meet my
brother he says is it any interest in it
do you have any anything for your
pockets he says no he says just subhana
waala and the angels tells him the angel
who took the form of the human he tells
him Allah subhana wa tala loves you too
just you love just you love
your brother for the sake of Allah
subhana tala so this is sincerity I mean
these are sincere Gatherings this is
where the s is being applied this is
where this no is being you know is
being presented and illuminated through
our hearts and through our faces and
through our conversations and all of
that you see a brother so many of you I
I I met today some of you I don't I did
not probably meet before and my heart
got enlightened right away yeah I never
I don't even know where you are from or
anything it's just it's a good
feeling and that's what we're talking
about that's what we're talking about
so going back
to he made these enemies man look at
that he made the enemies I'm not saying
that he was an enemy with a sword he was
an enemy with a tongue he would be an
enemy with a
tongue later on throughout his life
benim they were non-believers at that
time in
Medina you know prophet he said we want
you to become
Muslims they said we're not going to
become Muslims unless you come with the
best and the
best if you can come with the best sh
and the best and the best sh the best
wins over our best sh end of the story
we become
Muslims why if I tell you this right now
many of you will say is Iman about
who speaks better wins the competition
and then all of a sudden we just become
the Muslim the whole
tribe think about the way how they
thought, 1400 years ago when a person
would speak when they would speak about
poetry and you know delivering the
lecture the Arabs they would know who is
Sincere in what he says and who is not
they didn't have TVs back in the days
they didn't have all of these radios and
all of these you know you know toys that
we possess nowadays and now somebody
speaks to us on the TV and we
believe he saying the truth definitely
he say the truth and we're not sure for
that or somebody when he speaking the
truth when he says
yeah he he's bad he's no good we're not
able why because we we are so
influenced by different sources that we
don't even have control on we don't even
know all of a sudden CNN Pops in front
of you and
you're you believe everything you
see you
know so this is the problem that we face
now so back 1400 years ago they didn't
have these problems they were able to
tell who's honest who's not honest who
saying the truth and who's not saying
the
truth even the enemies
ofam they would say we know that this is
not a human word we know that this is
coming from some other sources
J you're connected to jins
you're they call him magician they call
them Gins connection with jins and we
know that it's not a human so they were
able to understand to realize that these
words are not human words these are
Divine words but they didn't want to
give the right you know to give the
credits to the to the Creator they just
gave the credits to The Jans to the to
the gins
so going back to Hass
bit that's why they asked you know they
want to see how deep inside they're
affected by this message of
sallam and he started talking you know
they said you know they The Poets
started poetry blah blah blah blah blah
blah the started speaking and all of a
sudden it was the turn of of Hass binit
and then after that was another that I
can't remember right now his his name
from Medina he was yeah it's not a
problem he started speaking as well and
then they said we are the losers I mean
we lose this
competition they saw this
no they recognized this no that existed
in Hassan see you're talking about an
enemy all of a sudden being the light
for the whole tribe of
Ben who can turn these people like
this except somebody who is a direct
messenger of Allah subhah wa tala nobody
else has the power to do this
nobody so and Iman is not something that
you're just convinced rationally you
just think about something oh yeah I
agree with your idea no it's more than
that it's a believe that penetrates and
you live according to that for the rest
of your life it is more than just a
theory it is more than just a
rationality it is a penetration of your
heart so going back
to again
W Allah is telling us that it is not
what he says what he utters these are
not just his own
words I mean somebody took a special
care of this person we educated
him we left him without a father we left
him without a mother we left him without
his grandfather we left him without
children except you know fa
zah you know his two boys young boys
abdah ibraim all they passed away you
know girls pass passed away I mean he
had no children Arabs they used to
feel so powerful for leaving you know
boys behind and boys protecting them and
this and that none of that in a way
Allah is teaching you and me that look
even though he does not have the worldly
strength and the worldly support but he
has the Heavenly support and that's me
he
says it is God the one who taught me the
ethics not my father not my
he's what a great ethics he has
given so beside This n That he left
behind that we all all owe him we know
Allah because of him he taught us who
Allah
is he introduced us with
Allah he introduce us with our
creator beside this fact about this
world brothers and sisters we have
another reason that we need to love him
more than anything
else and that is the
Hereafter that is the why well let me
give you an example if somebody really
loves you let's say Your mother or your
father what do they do for
you let's
say they will buy you a house you don't
have to pay any single dinero for that
it's all free for you live for the rest
of your
life or and they would pay for your
school they say you don't need to get a
loan it's all free go be a doctor it's
all free for
you or let's say you have another friend
of yours who would say you know what hey
man I want a million I want to share
with you $300,000 here it's yours do
whatever you want to do with
it I mean you don't forget that for the
rest of your life true or not true true
right you don't forget that person for
the rest of your life he has a special
place in your heart you say
alhamdulillah God met me with this
person where have you been well I
haven't seen you before that you know so
for the rest of your life you know this
or you know being an immigrant in my
case
most of you are immigrants when you
first came here who gave you the first
hand who laid the hand to say hey you
know what let me help you out let me
show you how to do this let me take you
this let me give you this if you needed
some money let me and for the rest of
our lives maybe they didn't put so much
efforts but because they were there for
us when we really needed somebody we
never forget them in our life and this
is true and probably 99% of us you guys
seem all immigrants including me so
probably all of you
you know went through this problem
trouble and you will remember these
people for the rest of your life
okay we as Muslims believe that there is
a
Hereafter and we believe that not
everything ends here this is only a
temporary place where we stay for some
time and then we go to our wat that's
our real W that's our real place where
we come from we come from there and we
go back to there we're just temporary
here this is not our what even if it's
Iraq or Albania or Pakistan that's not
that's
your that's your real because you come
from it you go back to it okay so now we
know that we're going to go back to
it who's going to intercede on your
behalf wasam and we know from manyi
that Prophet is going to do
the the other prophets they will be
sitting on Thrones on that day on the
day of the Resurrection when the people
will be walking through the and sallam
will be standing right there by theat
and he will say oh God make it easy for
these
people make it easy for these
people he's asking Allah subh to make it
easy on you to guarantee a bright future
ahead of
you before that he will be prostrating
on the S when everybody
saying
even everybody even the prophets my my
own self my own
so they will be concerned preoccupied
with the resting place of themselves
they say what's going to happen to me
why because they see a day of horror
it's not a day of vacation it is not a
day of taking it easy it is a day when
the sweat is going to be above heads to
some people and for some others will be
to the knees and to the you know to the
midwaist of theirs so we're talking
about a day full of surprises
and that day when we need most of the
help all of a sudden comes in the
picture and he's on S he's not sitting
on those Thrones as the this Hadi are
quoted by byed in his and so on and so
on I'm not quing to you right now at
least
minimum so he will be on the S
and Allah subh will say ask what do you
want ask and you will it will be given
to
you
wasallam and some Scholars they say this
is the
m you know that Prophet sallallahu alhi
wasallam will have you know the Dua we
make after the the